tan moms now on the Cameo Network you
talking about that thing where you can
go on and people pay you for doing
greetings no she's charged him $45 a
video can someone contact her did so
please cut a message to Jason and tell
him how important homework is and I have
to say she seems really dedicated to
helping this kid I mean she went on for
like a pretty long time this is great I
just want to take the time to tell you
how important school is and homework I
know after a long day at school
you might not want to do it but you
could put your homework into music you
could sing out your homework that taught
me a lot
I'm not necessarily so her tip is that
the kid should sing his homework yes and
that worked for her she learned a lot
that way I love music it's the
motivation that you need to do better I
want to meet the mom that hired tan mom
to lecture her kid on homework and I
wouldn't send you a shirt she sends a
shirt tube for the 45 bucks Bobby she's
gonna go bankrupt right I don't know
she's does she realize she's trying to
make money and I love you okay and I
want you to know how important school is
without school no there's no motivation
hmm the motivation you will find I have
five children homework is and will
become my mom why did I just get a shoe
in the mail from tan mom I thought I was
getting a shirt and then you put on this
special shirt that I'm gonna send you
every time you do your homework and
every time you go before you go to bed
say a little prayer single little note
maybe your mom and dad will get you a
little paper quarter and I'll send you a
CD to motivate you tan Tony Robbins
she's gonna do more talking she's saying
if this kid does his homework he should
record this
and send it to tan mom okay no I will do
whatever it takes
Wow because homework is the key to life
Yop to success and I want you to be
motivated and I for free if you want I
will give you my number before homework
time and you can always call me jeez my
god
now that's $45 worth please let me be
there for you to see you because you're
free to be Jason the most special person
in the world so of course Amen when we
listen to this amen amen yeah when we
listen to this rule like okay someone's
got to be Jason and get help with his
homework so here we go hello oh is this
tan mom yeah
I want to point out she falls for it
every time you know Jason sounds like a
nursing home this is Jason you left me
the Cameo message remember oh my god I'm
so excited about that you said I could
call you anytime if I needed help with
my homework okay so like what was the
civil war and like like who is the
president and stuff I believe it was
Jepsen
when was the Cold War now you want to
talk about Hitler
what there was a pathetic man that
destroyed every Jewish person I mean
that was the Cold War right right okay
very good
what is lava lava yeah I really had a
rough morning this is way much Jonathan
Oh from Star Wars no I mean yeah that
makes perfect sense
what is the H stand for an h2o it feel
yeah the H what what is named Einstein
Einstein I had to get ready okay I have
one last question I can't believe you're
plugging my brain right now
but it's 5 times 3:15 wait a minute no
11 okay
I'm gonna Ace this test I was hit about
the locker by well you're gonna need it
she certainly keeps her word she helped
him with his homework